on Monday Matt bought a Bitcoin
yesterday he shopped with Bitcoin today
he's putting on his professors tweed
jacket with suede elbow patches oh I
wish if only I might buy one of your big
ones you are here to give us a lesson on
how a Bitcoin transaction actually right
so the first couple days I was learning
a lot from the internet from reddit from
Bitcoin the soaking it up community and
now a lot of people who are uninitiated
have asked me hey I saw your piece how
does that work how can I get a Bitcoin
so just so you know how it work I put
together a very simple kind of view from
35,000 feet and it starts with obviously
changing your dollars or your euros or
yen or whatever you've got into bitcoins
now I've Illustrated this by putting a
regular wallet with dollars and then a
digital wallet here you've gotta go
while it looks like yes it looks like a
more like a clutch doesn't it but
there's the maze I would love to see you
there's the binary matrix thing there so
let me explain wallets because you have
to get a wallet before you can do any
kind of Bitcoin transaction for a
consumer for someone who's looking to
just spend money it works like a regular
wallet you spend out of it you can get
money into it for a merchant or producer
a vendor service provider whatever it
kind of works like a cash register now
in order to make a transaction happen
each wallet has two keys a private key
and a public key if you're selling
something or if you're accepting Bitcoin
you show someone your public key and
that is the QR code that you see there
you can take a picture of that key with
your wallet if you're a buyer and then
it generates a numeric code that's
random when those two things come
together the private key your private
key and the vent and the merchants
public key it makes a transaction now
those transactions all go into blocks
where you could think of it as a page on
a ledger and there are hundreds or
thousands of big mining operations there
that are competing to try and verify and
secure those blocks as a reward they get
25 Bitcoin I'd only get too into the
weeds but what they do is they wrap a
kind of digital
armored around each block each ledger
page and secure it they do it over and
over and over again so that the
transactions are all irreversible so
it's a really interesting procedure and
what happens though there's a fixed
number of bitcoins there happens to
these mining operations that seem so
critical to the transaction process when
they can no longer be rewarded with new
bitcoins well and actually there are
more and more miners out there to try
and get the 25 Bitcoin reward for each
block that they mined every four years
that's going to be 25 Bitcoin is almost
25 go exactly but every 4 years it will
be here tomorrow grant only 12 and a
half Bitcoin two in four years and by
2040 it will only be worth one Bitcoin
so the incentive is reduced but the
value I think the people in the crime a
community assumable do you have to leave
it there but it's day 3 are you a buyer
are you a seller hi I am going to go to
chip Brioni tomorrow we're going to have
a meeting of Bitcoin people and maybe
I'll buy another one
no I'm saying of Bitcoin how do you feel
out of it I'm real I think it's a really
interesting community it's a nascent
currency some like the president of
PayPal say it really is a commodity not
a currency yet because of the flood
that's a very good point